[Music]
hey guys Dan and Eddie here with some
fishing gameplay from Far Cry 5 we had
some time with Far Cry 5 recently you
can check out our impressions as well as
a bunch of other gameplay videos
including if it's more exciting for you
bunch of shooting with the bodies and a
mission with boomer the dog companion
but for now here's what we did we spent
how long did we play this game for Eddy
probably about an hour yeah I would say
like 45 minutes of that was spent with
you and I having a fishing competition
I mean fishing in this game I mean I'd
love fishing if you saw the feature I've
made that abundantly clear
maybe that's great maybe that's not but
you know fishing is great and you know
in other games they don't handle it in
the same way that far crack 5 does I
mean the fishing system in this game is
actually a fairly robust yes so it's you
have to actually think about where
you're casting how you cast and reeling
in and also keeping in mind the tension
on the line when you're when you're
reeling in fish is all right exactly I
mean just like in real life you know you
want to be reeling in when the fish is
not exactly fighting as strong as it
could be because then you potentially
might lose the fish or you know snap the
line so there is like a lot of thinking
that goes in you know involved in into
the fishing and in that way it kind of
you know mirrors the way it works in
real life which can it's something you
might want to do in Far Cry 5 if you're
looking for a little downtime it's not
always the most exciting thing to do but
it is satisfying throw in a fish I think
I think that that's something that's
worth noting is it's not exciting as
like per se it's like quite a relaxing
diversion which is something that Far
Cry games I think have really oh man
only two point seven pounds for pathetic
fish I think that's something that we've
written that Farah has been crying out
for is something else to do that isn't
just chaos
but that being said though chaos can
still happen when you're fishing
absolutely it can so if you're standing
near you know Shore or wherever year
yeah as you can see in the clip here
anything can happen in the background I
mean this is a far cry game and if
you're just fishing you want to be
careful that just be aware of your
surroundings because you know a wolf
might come up and just attack you yeah
or it's just there's some wolves just
ate a cow for some reason so you can
check out all about far cry 5 coverage
and all of our coverage of video games
in general so we're going to leave you
now with some nice relaxing shots of us
pulling up some trout and some sturgeon
in Far Cry 5 thanks for watching
[Music]